You are listening to
radio lab radio from W.
N y. S. T. E. N. N. P. R.
This is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich. Right.
So let me explain to you how
I got got started with this.
You were at some kind of an
affair. I'll tell you how good.
I was at a party party. Uh, it was a,
it was a conference where they have a
lot of different people of different
disciplines come together,
you know, one of those. Um,
there are panel discussions
of various things. It's,
we were at one of the
like functions and, uh,
it was a situation where like dinner
hadn't yet been served and there was a lot
of booze being served, so everybody
was like drunk on an empty stomach.
So I was standing there with some
biologists. Oh, they're the fun ones.
The junk biologists. Yes. As night. My
people barely. And uh, they, uh, we were,
they, they started to lose their shit,
like genuinely lose their shit about
this thing called CRISPR. And like,
I've never seen scientists this
excited about anything. So I was like,
what is this thing?
Wake up, what is CRISPR?
And they were trying to explain it to me,
but they couldn't slow down
enough for me to get it.
I gathered it had something
to do with genetics.
And then at 1.1 of the biologist
turned to me and was like,
I'll tell you what it is. I can use
CRISPR to take a little dog and Poof,
make it into a big dog.
Give me a Chihuahua.
I can turn it into the size of a great
Dane. And I was like, no, you can't.
He's like, yes I can. I could
do it with crisper. I was like,
what the hell is this thing? Do
you want me to sit here as usual?
If you sit here, I will get out,
let me know, imply I, no, no, no,
no, no. We'd be sitting here together.
So what happened was I came back and I
immediately called science writer Carl
Zimmer because I just figured for this
kind of thing, this is a Carl thing.
I got to talk to Carl. So I a, I
basically asked them like, while the fuss,
maybe it was just the alcohol or,
but maybe there's something
really happening here.
Oh, there's something totally
happening here. I mean, it's big.
He started at the beginning so that
you can actually find like the first
reference to CRISPR in a 1987 paper
from some Japanese scientists.
They basically described something
weird in Nikolai and they said,
we don't know what this is.
Ecola are bacteria inside humans.
And like all living things equalize made
up of DNA, A's and t's and C's and g's.
And what happened was that
these scientists were reading
a chunk of that genetic
code when
they found this really
strange stretch of DNA.
Strange how well, so
basically what it was, um,
was five identical sequences
in a row.
And then they were separated by very
short sequences in between them that were
all different from each other.
These little blurbs, it'd be like,
okay,
[inaudible]
and they looked at this and
they're like, well, what,
this is nothing like we've seen before.
Repeated sequences in
bacterial are kind of unusual.
Seems very strange. Some
biologists felt that, you know,
there must be a purpose for these among
those purposes. Eagers Jennifer Doudna,
University of California Berkeley.
She's a cell biologist, so it's Doudna.
Not Dude. No, it's Doudna.
I used to be called the dude
sometimes in the in school,
but in the movie she will be played
by Jeff Bridges. Right. Anyhow,
as time goes on,
scientists are seeing these little
repeat blurp repeats everywhere. Yes.
Releasing bacteria, lots and lots of
lots of species of bacteria. They say,
okay, wait a minute. That's
kind of cool. Their findings,
it so often that they decided they had
to give it a name and this is this where
the named CRISPR comes from. The full
official name is clustered regularly.
Interspaced short palindromic
repeats. Oh my God.
I don't know why they called it
CRISPR. It's kind of a CRISPR.
It's like a furniture manufacturer or
something. It sounds like an app. Yeah,
yeah. CRISPR. CRISPR, but now
scientists had this puzzle.
If nature at this level
preserved something intact. Here,
I'm here and here and here and here and
here and some of these here's or are
creatures that have been around for
hundreds of millions of years. You figure,
well, whatever this is, it's
doing something, doing something,
but what it doesn't take very long
before the first big clue comes up.
All right,
fast forward 2005 now scientists have
these big searchable databases of DNA
sequences, so some scientists
think, well, let's do a search.
Let's see if these repeating
patterns. We keep finding match.
Anything else that's out there in the
world and the scientists are using
computers to just line up these stretches
of DNA with thousands upon thousands
of different species and then click.
All of a sudden they discover that
those bits of DNA between the repeats,
the stuff in the middle of those blurps,
these are matching virus DNA.
Like you can find viruses
with genes where these little,
you know these little to the bacteria
had virus inside of them. Yup.
I mean that,
that a virus brought it into these cells
will tell you anything but the origin
of it. The first recognition
was this is virus DNA.
Somehow all these bacteria have little
snippets of virus DNA wedged in these
particular places in their genome,
which is a little weird
if you think about it.
I mean these are totally
different creatures.
They would be like inside a human
finding, a little bit of mosquito DNA.
You're want, how do we interpret this?
Well, actually there was one scientist,
his name is Eugene Koonin who looked
at these results and just said, okay,
I get it. It's a defense
system. Why would he think that?
Because he's a brilliant
man. What do you mean?
If I went to a large sanitation dump
and I found a team bit of human hair,
why would I think, oh, I got it. It's a
defense mechanism. I wouldn't know it.
Just like a bitty human,
right. Well, you see I,
that metaphor might sort of betray
your lack of skill and microbiology.
I'm just saying like this
is not a dump. All right.
This is bacteria are not gonna just let
virus DNA get into their genes willy
nilly. Okay. Remember, viruses
are the big enemy, right?
If your bacteria, viruses
make your life a nightmare,
think about it in the ocean. Okay.
The, the ocean is full of viruses and,
and uh,
viruses kill up to 40% of all
of those bacteria every day.
Really? Every day. Yeah. And we
know that they have defenses.
What Eugene Koonin said was, okay,
I'm going to bet that these bacteria
are somehow grabbing pieces of DNA from
viruses and then they're storing it and
now they have a way of recognizing those
viruses if they come in later,
a little Polaroid shots
of the enemy, right? No,
thy enemy. Yeah, like a most wanted
poster. What do you call the Mugshot?
This is Eugene Koonin leader
of the evolutionary genomics
group at the National
Center for Biotechnology Information.
He's the guy that Carl referenced who
thunk up the whole idea that maybe these
bits of virus DNA inside the bacteria
is the bacteria trying to defend itself.
But really if I, if I, if I, if I
could eat myself with anything here,
it was not so much getting
this because you know, again,
you see the vague dentical sequence
that gets pretty obvious. It is
figuring out how the
mechanism was likely to work.
So can you walk us through how the
mechanism is likely to work? Oh right.
What happens if you know,
when a virus comes in
to a cell, I just kind of
explodes and just kind of
releases naked genes. Basically,
if you're this bacteria, these
things might take over your cell,
so you've got to respond,
move moonstruck the guy,
you have multiple weapons of defense.
If you've never seen this virus before,
it usually the first thing you do says
Eugene is you send out these enzymes to
attack the viruses.
They're sort of like the ground
troops and they fight really hard,
but much of the tie,
thank you
fail and then no one will
hear about you again.
They're not terribly
sophisticated fighters, so
very often various takes over.
The bacteria dies,
but [inaudible] very
fun nonzero probability
[inaudible]
that you actually survive it.
If you do then with the bacteria will
do is send in some new enzymes to
basically clean up to go out,
find any stray viruses and then caught
the enemy DNA into futile small pieces in
here. He says when you
get to the storage part,
those enzymes will then take those little
bits of virus and shove them into the
bacteria as own DNA,
right in those little spaces between the
repeats right there and nowhere else.
So I use those spaces in my
own DNA as a storage facility,
as a as a, you use it as a memory device
cause here's what happens
next time that virus shows up
sprays with jeans everywhere.
Now you are prepared and this is where
the CRISPR story really gets going
because instead of sending
out the ground troops,
we're probably going to
get their asses beat.
Now you can actually send out the big guns
and in fact what the cell does is it
will manufacture these special molecular
assassins and they'll give those assassins
a copy of that little bit of virus
DNA it has in stores. Basically
saying, here, take this mugshot.
If you see anything that
matches this pattern, kill it.
And these attackers, do we know what
they, one of them looks like. Yup.
So we know what the protein looks
like. It, it actually looks,
I would describe it, um, a little bit
like a clamshell sort of imagine pack man,
but kind of misshapen and rough
in each one of these guys.
What it has is a copy of that virus DNA.
It's got the mugshot that
it's kind of waving around.
What then happens is that whenever
the PAC man bumps into some virus DNA,
it pulls apart the DNA
and zips. It reads it.
If it's not the right one, it goes on.
Nope,
sure.
[inaudible]
and if that RNA has the same sequence,
then click click. It just locks in.
And if that happens then the DNA is
trapped and molecular blades come out
and chop cartoon gets scared
that the mighty blow. Yeah.
Smart scissors too. It's like,
are you like the thing I got?
Are you like say I got your like
thing, I got sniff. Sniff. All right,
now we are going to kill. Oh,
I see. And it has to be exact.
It has to be an exact match.
When scientists first discovered this
whole system, they were fascinated.
They were like,
they were working it out.
They were like, oh, okay.
Then this happens and this
happens, this happens. Cool.
But then
in walks the dude,
Jennifer Doudna with a crazy idea,
I don't know if it's crazy radical.
This could be an amazing
technology. This is a tool.
This is a tool, right?
This is a tool that we can use to
cut DNA where we want to cut DNA.
The basic thought was, why don't
we turn this defense into offsets?
Cause these things,
they seem to be really good at cutting
and yet they only seem to cut the things
that are on their mugshot.
So maybe I could just replace
what's on their mugshot.
So instead of them going after viruses,
maybe they could go after a gene that
causes Huntington's disease or hemophilia,
for example. And this is actually
something that's been done.
So you've got a mouse with
something like hemophilia. Okay?
This is a disease is
caused by one bad gene.
So what you do is you take
these little surgeons,
you give them the mugshot for the bed
gene, then you stick the surgeon
with the new mugshot and a mouse.
Then you set it loose and just
like it's the program too,
it will find that gene and
click, click chop.
Yes.
Scissors will end up cutting exactly
the gene you wanted to cut to,
the bad genes gone. Now the question is
how do you put in the good gene? Right,
right, right.
It turns out actually
according to Jennifer Doudna
now that that's actually not
as hard as you would think. Really. Yeah.
Apparently what you do is just throw
this new good gene kind of in the
neighborhood of where they all genius
to be just in the general vicinity.
You don't have to get super precise. I
mean, it turns out that, um, you know,
there are repair enzymes that are probably
continually surveying and checking
for breaks. And she says, what'll
happen is it inside the cell,
these repair crews come
along, they'll see the break,
they'll see the good Jean just
sitting there next to the break,
there'll be like, all right,
I'll just stick it in and split the
pretty guy in this space. Exactly. So,
so we take advantage of a natural
repair pathway that cells have.
They trick both the cutters
and the fixers. Yeah.
Now we're not assassinating anymore.
Now we're actually engineering.
We've gone from killing to refashioning.
[inaudible]
well though, haven't we been
designing jeans doing genetic,
a form of genetic engineering for, I
don't know, like 30 years. Yes, but
not like this.
[inaudible]
genome editing technologies have
been around for a long time,
but none of them have been
as powerful as CRISPR is.
That's Beth Shapiro from UC Santa Cruz.
She was actually one of the biologists
that I drunkenly talked to at that thing.
Was it a modern art museum?
I can't even really remember.
I don't remember either.
It must've been quite an evening to
have the setting be so vague. Anyhow,
here's how she put it
to us. Back in the day,
this was just like two years ago you
would have these gene editor or things you
would take one,
put it in a cell and what happened
before was you would give it on some
instructions about where to go and
it might go there but it might go to
somewhere. That's kind of
related to where that was.
It's like you just dig it right? Its
Staten Island but it takes a left,
not only would it take a left
Staten Island and not find there,
but it would've cost you a fortune and
taken up six months of your time to get
that thing and now you
know it's really easy.
You just give it that mugshot and it
goes, I'm going to find that to guy.
Exactly. So it seems to be
pretty precise and it's cheap.
Like the old tools would set you back
about five grand just to use them once
CRISPR but 75 bucks. And
here's the kicker, says Carl,
it seems at the moment that you can
take these things out of bacteria,
stick them into almost any other creature
and it still works. You can use
the same CRISPR system on anything.
Can you like do it? If corn
is vulnerable certain past,
you can do it in corn and corn,
do it in anything. I have not.
I'm waiting for someone to say CRISPR
doesn't work in species x and I have not
heard of that.
So basically what you have for the first
time in science is this gene editing
technology that is cheap,
precise, and possibly universal.
And Jennifer Doudna says the moment,
the full impact of that landed on her.
I really, I literally had, you know,
the hairs on the back of
my neck were standing up
just processing the fact that
this thing exists, you know,
and that you could actually program it
to cut DNA and just like this molecular
scissors and I can just program
it and it cuts DNA. Roder I want
it is amazing unless you
think about it further,
which we will do in just a moment.
I feel a cloud coming in over their
eyes and just over there, TC. I see you.
Let's get a certain horizon mark
over there, but we'll be right back.
Hi, this is Lauren from Atlanta, Georgia.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hey guys, this is Alison
calling from Luxembourg.
Radiolab is supported by rocket
mortgage by quicken loans.
Rocket mortgage brings the mortgage
process into the 21st century.
With this completely online process,
safely share your bank statements and
pay stubs with the touch of a button.
Ditch the paperwork and use your phone
or tablet to get approved for purchase or
refinance in minutes.
Get a custom mortgage solution
whenever and wherever you want.
Check out rocket mortgage
today@quickenloansdotcomslashradiolabequalhousinglenderlicensedinallfiftystatesandanlsconsumeraccess.org
number 30 30 hi,
I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab is
supported by Google and Squarespace.
Make your business official
with Google and Squarespace.
When you create a custom domain and
a beautiful business website with
Squarespace, you'll receive
a free year of business,
email and professional tools from Google.
It's the simplest way to
look professional online,
visit.com/google to start your free trial.
Use the offer code document for
10% off on your first purchase.
Google and Squarespace. Make it
professional. Make it beautiful.
This is Radiolab, mom jad up and Ron,
I'm Robert Krulwich. Okay, so, uh,
clearly the possibilities are there
to use CRISPR to treat disease, right?
Right. But what if you could get
a little more fanciful, right?
Like what if you could actually go
back in time and resurrect long lost
creatures. I mean, this is something
that Best Shapiro has talked about a lot.
We could reconstruct using a computer
what the genome sequence of the ancestor
of all birds was and that would
have been a kind of dinosaur.
And then we could use crispers to
turn a chicken into that thing.
Or what if you could take an
elephant and snip, snip, snip,
gradually turn it into
its long lost relative,
the woolly mammoth. No, cause they're
related. But if they're there,
they're similar over. Well, right. But
if you know the woolly mammoth genome,
which they do cause they apparently
got it off some bone or some hair,
then you could compare the number of
differences you use CRISPR to crisper out
the different parts of the elephant
and put in wooly mammoth and stuff.
If you can in effect, go backwards
in time and make changes.
And obviously I think you can go
the other way too, right? I mean,
humans are good at design.
We're designing animals.
So if it doesn't seem to me to be a crazy
notion to imagine parents all over the
world wanting, I don't
know, taller children.
So silencing the short jeans
and favoring the taller jeans,
getting rid of weak muscles and going for
stronger ones and on and on and on and
on. I don't know where
the designing stops.
We sort of got into all of this with
uh, Carl Zimmer, science writer.
If, if you can be very,
very gene specific and you learn
more and more about genes over time,
why couldn't you invent a creature?
Why couldn't you make a pig with wings?
You might one day get
sophisticated enough to do that.
There's no wing at pig lab. You know,
the best you're going to hope for
right now is a woolly mammoth lab.
And that's down the hall from where
the, where the real action is,
is now there's a hall and
at the end of the hall,
a wing piglet has not been built
yet. It may be 20 years from now.
But that's what you're
looking at. Well, I think,
but the thing is that why shouldn't anyone
realize that that's really what we're
talking about? Well, because
you can't make weight.
We need the pigs just because of sort
of evolutionary barriers. Okay. Well,
there's no reason to fly a gentleman for
the job down. Come on down. I'm just,
I mean, okay. I,
I don't think that we need a federal
department of homeland piquing security.
I think we're okay there. All
right. Well we do need is like,
uh,
we do need to like figure out what are
we going to do about CRISPR and humans.
I mean, they're going to be
using CRISPR for cancer. Okay.
They're going to take people's immune
cells out of their body and they're going
to use CRISPR to basically
allow them to make proteins,
are going to be able to grab onto cancer
cells and attack their own cancer.
Yeah. That's to be for that. I mean, you
have to be, well, I don't know. I mean,
are you for that is your, your,
your, you talk, you are tink,
you are tinkering with someone's own body.
You are altering their
own cells. You know,
dude, where do I, it's just,
I tell you, look, was it,
this is me.
I don't know if it's a religious thought
or just the thought of a conservative
person, but I mean, I've, I grew
up in the, in the test to baby era.
I now know many wonderful adult
formerly test two babies. And I,
I remember being astonished
that no, so I can't,
I don't know where the sacred begins and
ends anymore on that particular turf.
I guess what I'm instead
on is I'm on, on, um,
a Hobbsy in view of human beings that
there is something about human beings
including scientists, human
beings, all human beings,
that there's a darkness and
a light there, there, there,
there's an angelic side to being human.
And here's a very, very difficult set.
And as the human beings get more and
more power to create and design and
essentially create a future,
that future will include the imaginations,
both light and dark of humans and
that will be new in the world.
Yeah.
I don't think it is new because if you
go back to the start of the scientific
revolution,
some like Francis Bacon
would say explicitly like
science is going to be both
about learning about how the world works
and using that knowledge to control it.
You know, this has been discovered.
This has been published.
Everybody knows it exists. Um, if
you're going to say like, okay,
now we're going to all,
we're going to outlaw this.
I'm not saying festing that
well. What are you suggesting?
I think we should cringe level as
opposed to just have a big part. Right.
That's all great. You
Ready? One, two, three.
[inaudible] what do we have? Cringed,
deny way. What do we do now? Well,
I don't know if that's
what you're arguing. No.
[inaudible] cringe too. You
cringed meanly and deep and you
Chris Chew Cummins with attitude
I don't pitching with with,
I would like because you're
afraid of like dragons.
You're saying?
You're saying, oh my God, yes,
I'm afraid of dragons. Okay,
so that conversation with Carl was four
months ago and a lot has happened in the
in in that time because to
the question that you asked,
like where does the sacred
begin and end? Well,
one of the lines that had been drawn by
Jennifer Doudna and others was that we
should not use this technology on
humans who haven't been born yet.
Meaning not on sperm cells or egg cells.
Because if you CRISPR say an embryo
that is a, that is a permanent,
right.
That is a change to the DNA that will
be passed on to their children and their
children's children and their
children's children's children.
And you can't ask the person if that's
okay because you're doing it before
they're born. Consent
becomes a real issue.
And if you imagine making these changes
and they cascade through generation
after generation, you could affect
the evolution of organisms. And it's,
I don't want to say trivial, but it's,
you know, it's fairly easy to do it. Wow.
It's kind of profound. I feel
it's really profound. Profound.
But it was just an idea that is until
for the first time in history,
researchers in China have successfully
edited the human genome and an embryo.
Just two months ago, it was announced
that a Chinese team from Estonia,
Watson University use a technique called
CRISPR to edit DNA than human embryos.
It's a way of hacking evolution itself.
Well, this is hugely controversial.
Now these embryos, the
Chinese team had edited,
they were created through
IVF and they were not viable.
But these are embryos that are, are not
going to actually develop into a person.
So they're, they're going to be
discarded anyway. It's still thinking,
figuring it out with those embryos. What's
to stop any of us from going further.
I ologist and bioethicists are sounding
an alarm scientists face accusations
that they crossed an ethical line that's
just sort of thing could be sort of a
slippery slope towards
toward designer babies.
Essentially genetically
engineering the human race
when I use the term chips to
kind of test your levels. Okay.
Now that the cringe party had spread
and Robert didn't seem like such a loon.
Yeah, we called up Carl again.
Well, we have to revisit,
we have to revisit it because in our
Iron Mageddon conversation in which I
believe I was extremely alarmist
and you were extremely down pudding,
I feel that I should do a
small little parade called the
[inaudible]. The Alamo is take remember,
remember China and you have to close.
You should just begin anytime you want.
Like getting on your knees
and saying how sorry you are.
I don't if you start from
there. Um, I'm sorry.
So are we actually surrounded by,
uh, an army of, uh,
clones with superpowers? Not yet. Not
yet, but I think the dyke has been open.
I believe, I'm going to
quote somebody who said, uh,
maybe a few weeks ago, I
think maybe it was last week,
even writing for National
Geographic. I think it was,
maybe it was somebody named
Carl who said that, uh,
the news from China and that news was
probably the beginning of an entire new
era. I think I actually said it was a
historical moment. That's right. Yes.
Yes. And I, and I still stand by that.
Do you feel differently now than
the first time we talked? Yeah,
that's really the question. I don't
feel different actually because,
um, there isn't really no
scientific surprise here. He says,
people have been doing all these CRISPR
experiments on all these different
mammals. We're mammals. This is
bound to happen. And in fact,
it may be happening more than we think.
Uh, in one account in the journal,
nature has said that for other Chinese
labs are doing this kind of work as we
speak. But Carl also told us,
which he said was unsurprising too,
but I actually find it kind of
surprising that the CRISPR worked.
This Chinese team did,
didn't work very well.
It worked kind of,
I mean,
in only a few of the cases did they
really get exactly what they wanted.
Um, they tried using CRISPR and about
86 embryos and they only get off to work
right.
And maybe 28 getting in and a lot of
them crispers made the wrong cuts and
screwed up the cells and that led them
to conclude that this is a technology
that's not ready right now for
application in the human
germline. And I agree, oh,
we're sort of,
we still are in this kind of a
fortunate position where we can say, oh,
well it's dangerous so we shouldn't
use it on in human embryos.
I just don't think that we're
going to be able to sort of, uh,
find refuge there in like 10 or 20
years. In 10 or 20 years. You know,
CRISPR will be so sophisticated
that people will be able to say,
I can get you the change you
want and I can do it safely.
I can guarantee you that you will have
human embryos that have the alteration in
the particular gene
you want. So then what,
in fact,
Jennifer Doudna told us
that this experiment or
similar experiments have been
repeated in mice with more
advanced CRISPR systems.
Cause apparently there are many
different kinds and they're,
it was done with almost no error.
Sometimes I feel like we're sort of
displacing all our ethical concerns onto
something that hasn't happened yet.
If we really are concerned about what
we're doing to the human gene pool,
you know, it's already here. Take
as an example, in vitro fertilization,
about 60,000 kids are born a year through
IVF and it's probable that some of
those parents chose whether they
wanted a boy or a girl. And, and
when people started doing IVF,
there was a huge controversy.
People said this was
dangerous. This is unnatural.
I don't see people who are unable to
sleep at night because of the existence of
IVF. Yeah, yeah. Now I'm going to sound
like I'm on Robert side of this. I mean,
okay. So, so I won't hurt. They won't.
It won't. It will. Okay. All right. Yeah.
Here we go. So, okay, so breath.
So you guys know about, uh,
all the stuff going on in Iceland where
they're looking at people's DNA and you
know, they're looking for
disease genes and so on.
And when they were looking
at these Icelandic people,
they found that some
people had a gene that, uh,
protects them against Alzheimer's. It
reduces their odds of getting Alzheimer's.
Let's imagine your doctor said now if
you'd like for an extra thousand dollars,
we will take these IVF embryos and we
will use CRISPR to give them the Alzheimer
protecting variant. Would you like that?
Do you want to add that to your,
to your procedure? Sure. Yeah.
Or would you like your
child to, to face a,
a future of, of Alzheimer's,
your choice. See,
here's my, here's my thing.
Here's my thing with this whole,
with this whole thing, I'm, I'm a little
bit haunted by the thing you said,
which is that when it's not
dangerous anymore, what will we do?
And I'm afraid we've already answered
that question, that it's not,
it's not a question that's open anymore
because if we're already doing this kind
of stuff and who's going to say no to
that? Who's going to say no to that?
That's what he just was
demonstrating. Yeah. Yeah.
We've already answered the question. Yeah.
We may have
[inaudible]
many thanks to science writer Carl
Zimmer has written many books.
You can check them
out@carlzimmer.com or@radiolab.org.
This piece was produced by Molly Webster.
We had original music this
hour by Eric Kowalski,
otherwise known as Cassino
versus Japan. Special.
Thanks to honor Russ Squid
Paz Lee Maguire, Dr. Blake,
we can have Dr Luciano Mar Fini,
Dr. John Burgess and Dr Jen Washy.
Uh,
I'm Jad Abumrad. I am Robert
Krulwich. Thanks for listening.
Uh,
to hear the message again. Press
two to delete it. Start of message.
Oh no calls number nine. This is Beth
Shapiro. Hello, this is Jennifer Doudna.
Radiolab is produced by Jada, the
right Brendan, Cheryl, Ellen, Lauren,
Dylan, Keith Matte, guilty
and Levy, but Keith Nasser,
Melissa O'Donnell, Kelby Padgett,
Arianne wack, Molly Webster,
Sean ruler, and Jamie are,
I think I said Webster.
Let me try it again with
help from Daddy Lewis,
Kelly crime and Damiano Marchetti.
Our fact checkers are Eva Dasher and
Michelle Harris. Awesome. Thank you.
Much redder and this message.